so we're getting this let's jump to the
story we have and we'll see what's going
on in the u.s cbs news reports u.s
truckers planning protest convoy perhaps
starting in la for super bowl dhs warns
that's right the department of homeland
security is warning an american convoy
may begin
if it's anything like what we saw in
canada it will work
it'll be very effective and uh
it'll probably end up winning and
they're already they're already starting
to pull back on the mandates that have
been so funny if you just went on to the
next story right after like i said we
should do that very much but uh but i am
wondering if this even a real story
i i know there have been conversations
about locking down the super bowl but
that seems weird to me almost like the
idea was seeded specifically to ruin the
freedom convoy because right now regular
people don't know like i'm talking about
average people sitting at home of which
there are very few because i think most
people are polarized they're like i
don't know a whole lot about what's
going on with that convoy thing but the
the manipulation the propaganda has
mostly failed you go on reddit and
people are like they're just
working-class dudes they're drivers the
propaganda propaganda's not working
well you want to piss off regular people
shut down the super bowl
and i'm i'm suspicious of you know dhs's
warnings it's like yeah you know i think
that
it it's highly it's likely that they
could be just sort of trying to say
there's a threat out there that that's
not really there to make it seem like
you know those extreme people those
truckers they're going to try to kill
your super bowl yeah public warnings
just don't make a lot of sense to me if
a military comes out and is like china
has you we think that china's ufo's like
come on dude what are you telling me for
yeah i don't you would only tell the
people that it's a need to know thing
they would tell la law enforcement about
this they wouldn't in surrounding years
they wouldn't be telling the public did
you see that clip of the journalist
arguing with the uh was it was dan price
what was it was the name i don't
understand i remember his name
the canadian guy no no no it's a
journalist talking to an american uh
official about russia's russia's false
flag attack because the u.s keeps saying
over and over again russia is going to
stage a false flag and then he's like
what proof do you have they're like well
we issued a transcript that's something
you said happened what proof you have
and then he goes
crisis actors are you k this is alex
jones stuff yeah and then he goes on to
mention i think like the wmds and like
the war in iraq i'm like that guy just
snapped something happened to him he
woke up and the narrative broke yeah he
was just out of the matrix
yeah and and the the the government guy
was going oh you're what are you on
putin's side yeah
i just it's so funny how we've returned
to that too uh i remember during the
2012 election when mitt romney said
something about russia being a growing
threat and of course he would he's like
an establishment swamp creature but the
response from the left was oh my
goodness isn't this hysterical you know
the 80s called they want their villain
back and then in 2016 when we're even
more removed from that era it's russia
russia russia what a strange villain
it's like we were joking about this in
in burn after reading when she she wants
to sell the information to the russians
and everyone in the city is like the
russians yeah why yeah like what would
they yeah well also because if if you're
not familiar with that movie the
information was nothing it's also the
information was it was nothing it was
like the russians like what i got a
question for you guys
if uh
a bunch of truckers
showed up um in dc
and then something happened that a mass
casualty event took the lives of these
truckers how do you think the left the
establishment left and many leftists
would react
mocking uh they would laugh until there
was no one to bring them their food yeah
exactly
they absolutely would laugh
they would celebrate it yeah that's
that's pretty scary
yeah i'd say they deserved it yeah maybe
look at what they do to ashley babbitt
you know it's like sometimes you get
glimpses of humanity from people like
jake tapper and stuff so maybe people
would be like this is it this is the
moment that it went too far well i guess
you know sometimes the brain slug that
infected his mind and took over his body
loses control
he's able to break out and he's like
just all of a sudden on cnn he's like i
love all of you honey i love you and you
made me think of the kent state shooting
in 1970 may 4 kent state i went to kent
state it was a big deal on campus these
four there was a big crowd of students
protesting vietnam and then the national
guard came out to try and quiet them
down they were throwing rocks at the
national guard they opened fire on the
crowd and killed four injured others
and it was a huge national
just a tragedy and it it basically was
the beginning of the end of vietnam neil
young song
yeah and uh buffalo springfield yeah
well deal was in buffalo springfield
yeah oh interesting yeah but the uh the
um for what it's worth that's such a
good thing yeah it's a great song but
the people who got who lost their lives
weren't protesters i'm pretty sure wait
um yeah neil was in buffalo street but
when the when the shooting real estate
happened yeah it was bystanders it's
just people who are on campus walking by
one guy sit on that hill there was also
injuries one guy took a bullet through
his his wrist i think and it paralyzed i
would sit on the hill and envision all
the people and just think about it
sometimes it's crazy one thing here and
i mean this almost in some ways makes it
more frightening but i'll issue a caveat
to this idea of left-wing people
hypothetically laughing in the situation
and we seem to believe that many of them
would i think there's also an argument
to be made that those among them who
have some level of
of empathy for their opposition and
don't necessarily hate everyone who
stands in their way would still feel
pressure to not care about the loss of
life because as soon as they stood up
and said these are human beings they'd
be rejected because that's exactly what
happens then when they say that about
the unborn or any other group that the
left is okay with the death of zombie
horde
yeah yeah it's it's it's it's mindless
you know
that we were talking about this with
your film your agent you know getting
fired
these are people who don't care about
the truth they don't want to hear the
truth they just want to hate yeah they
want to be a part of it
imagine a mob of people with pitchforks
and torches
they don't know they don't care they're
just going to do whatever the mob does
i've watched it happen in real time i've
been in these major protests where i've
seen people lose it and attack random
people i was in san jose during that uh
infamous trump rally i felt i filmed a
guy getting smacked in the back of the
head with a bag of what we think were
rocks oh wow went viral overnight and
there was also a guy who got beat up
because they just someone decided to
beat him up and the mob just said that's
the guy we're beating up turns out he
was a part of the mob
there was a kid some 16 year old kid was
walking on the street someone started
attack chase running after him the whole
mob chased after him
it's absolutely insane but that's what
we're dealing with the i i i suppose
i'll put it this way
if you've got
liberals conservatives moderates you
know traditionalists progressives
that are all in alignment but they all
agree with liberty and and being
inquisitive so there's like uh jimmy
dore jimmy dore is progressive and lefty
but he believes in the truth so we like
the guy you know because you know we
disagree on politics acro you know all
day and night
it's clear that the what divides us is
not policy
it is simply there is a
a mob of people that want to be a mob
and there's everyone else who want to
live and understand and solve problems
those are the two groups that are
clashing right now
and the left is kind of the the way
they've been brought to this point by
the democrat party and the leaders in
that movement is
is they've been told over and over again
you are the good people
and it's that self-righteousness of like
that surety and that self-righteousness
those people over there are bad they
hate gays they hate black people they
hate everybody you know you're one of
the good people so no matter what they
say we we have to remain above them i
was having a deep conversation last
night um about this and about after 9
11. all of a sudden this narrative of
good and evil started getting shoved
down my throat by george bush and
everybody else around him and it was
like they're bad you're good we're the
heroes god's on our side good versus
evil good versus evil then superhero
movies start coming out good versus evil
where people are brainwashed they think
it's good versus evil now it's
terrifying
well i don't know what it is good versus
no it's not trust me it's not
ian would that be not there's
destruction and creation but
all the other stuff is perspective there
it's just you're just wrong
i understand i want you to think that
they want you polarized maybe i
understand what you're saying but uh
someone swatted us and we got sweated
twice
and why would we get swatted a second
time is it evil to try and kill someone
because they have conversations you
don't like
well like i just said man there's
creation and destruction and then it
depends on who you ask if i'm going to
give you a different answer than
everyone else though so give me your
answer what's the question again yeah
from what you said killing someone for
what trying to get someone killed group
of people killed because they have
conversations you don't like oh for me
that i think that is terrible now now
who would disagree with you
the people trying to kill the person
having the conversation
well to them you're the evil i mean
that's all perspective who's telling the
story who's in control of the narrative
so i agree with you that people have
different perspectives but some
perspectives are wrong that's the point
and they would say the same thing and
they would be wrong it's okay to say i'm
right and you're wrong but it's okay to
be wrong also
not but not any longer than you have to
be as soon as you get the new
information that shows that your
previously held assumptions were
incorrect you have an obligation to
accept those i think
99.9 percent of humanity has agreed that
killing people for no reason is wrong
and uh a smaller is a slightly large uh
large single digit percentage probably
agrees with pre-emptive murder for the
sake of ideology like if the most you
know
the president is so dangerous it's okay
to get rid of like 80 000 citizens yeah
communism tend to be you know that's the
american government the american
government did that the the democratic
republic of the united states
murdered citizens for that
but you're yeah you're arguing that
that's evil it is evil yes
but people don't think people are like
hey the ends justify the means because
that guy's so dangerous but sometimes
that is so dangerous like hitler ian ian
you are incorrect
on the right and the left there is
populist unity that invading foreign
countries and blowing people up is wrong
what about nazi i mean what about
firebombing dresden to stop hitler
you're where's the evil you're talking
about
a response
so like if some guy in a house
starts breaking in other people's homes
and killing people and then we go
and he's in in one of the houses so
we're like the only thing we can do to
stop this guy is burn the house down but
you know might hurt somebody else like
this guy's already killed so many people
that's called the difficult decision
this is good because i think you're
talking about individual one-on-one
interactions there now we can start to
get a nuance of good and evil but in the
in the society it's dangerous to slap
that label around well yeah i mean
whether you're talking about like uh
firebombing dresden or firebombing tokyo
or nuclear uh bombs being dropped in
hiroshima and nagasaki you can agree
that one particular side of the conflict
was correct and had to win while also
saying this was objectively morally evil
you should not make civilians a target
of warfare that's a position you can
hold
but you're not saying but that doesn't
mean
no no you're not saying that you're
saying like actually they shouldn't have
done that they were i was on their side
or am on their side but i don't think
that that's something they should have
done you can agree with you can side
with somebody and still say but don't do
that you're not pledging like undying uh
agreement with everything they do or
have done let me let me let me explain
something for you ian
if i say
i've reviewed as much evidence as i can
from what happened on january 6 and
there are some people who did some some
things that were very wrong and should
be held accountable and there are some
people that are being harassed and even
tortured by the government and that's
wrong
i'm
i'm trying to be as objective and honest
as possible
to be fair and just to as many people as
i can so that we can all live in harmony
trying to help people flourish
stopping the bad stopping the pain
stopping the suffering and promoting
growth is typically a good thing
when you have other organizations that
lie on purpose to to to create
destruction and cause pain and suffering
and then lie to convince people that
we're the evil ones that's evil
i know man but now we're talking about
like living living like living and lying
and knowing you're lying and acting
anyway
i i know this phone is made by slaves i
know that and i'm doing it anyway yeah
and and so what am i living a lie just
walking around like a lot of you
acknowledge that it's thankful yeah like
if they were here i would i wouldn't be
like la dee da i'd be like free these
guys but they're they're they're out of
sight out of mind so i know it but ian
but so but what i'm catching it
i think you actually believe so firmly
and deeply in morality that you're
arguing for moral consistency but you're
seeing that as saying that morality
doesn't exist i really think on some
level you do believe in good and evil
you just aren't acknowledging it i
really think you do because you get
really upset when a person is
hypocritical about their moral values
and why would that be upsetting for you
if good and evil weren't real i think
you're right i i do believe i am good
but i am a product of my parents and
what they told me good is but did you
choose to accept that definition and
have you chosen to act on it
because that is your own free will yeah
that's not just yourself it jived with
society so i accepted it is that why you
accepted it basically are you going to
tell them you've never made a moral
decision because you thought it was the
right thing to do and not because it
judges society i've done that too
exactly
exactly so you can't just say well it's
all relative and it's all my parents at
some point you made choices
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time